أطفال يلعبون بالمرح في رواق
مخصص لاستضافة ألعاب الليزر تاغ ،
لكن هذه ليست أوقاتًا عادية ،
حوّل المالكون هنا
أعمالهم الترفيهية لأطفالهم إلى
ملجأ مؤقت مكان لإيواء العشرات من
الأوكرانيين الذين فروا
لتوهم من مدينة ميدوبل الساحلية المحاصرة.
الأسبوعان الماضيان كانا
مثل الجحيم ديميتري شويتز ، هربت زوجته
تانيا وابنتهما فلادا من
ماريوبول يوم الخميس ،
لقد عانوا أسابيع من
القصف الروسي من القصف المدفعي
والغارات الجوية كل 15-20 دقيقة ،
يمكنك الاستماع إلى
الطائرة وكأنها مستهدفة وبعد ذلك
صوت
[موسيقى]
تانيا احتفظت بمجلة في
اليوم الثاني من يوم 7 من الحرب لم يتغير شيء ،
فهي لا تكتب أي كهرباء أو
تدفئة ولا توجد مياه جارية الآن كما
عاشوا في الطابق السفلي وعندما
ظهروا التقطت تونيا صورًا ومقاطع فيديو
لمبنى شقتهم
[ __ ] بثقوب الرصاص
قذائف غير منفجرة في الشوارع السكنية
أناس يائسون ينهبون قنبلة دمرت
متجرًا للطعام  المشكلة هي المياه ،
لا يوجد ماء للشرب ،
بحثوا عن مياه الشرب وسحبوا
الدلاء من مجاري الشوارع ،
مرحبًا ، كنا نأخذ المياه من
مياه الأمطار ونأخذ المطر في انتظار
القصف العنيف لمياه الأمطار على المنازل المجاورة ،
كتبت تانيا في الخامس من مارس / آذار ،
ذهبنا جميعًا  للنوم مع التفكير في
كيفية البقاء على قيد الحياة والبقاء على قيد الحياة
ذات يوم انفجرت قذيفة بالقرب من ديميتري بينما
كان يقف في طابور القنبلة المائية
سقطت وقتلت مثل ثلاثة أشخاص
أمامنا
كان رجل بلا رأس
يشبه أخذ الماء للآخر
واحد في الصف كان مثل نصف
الرأس وآخر واحد قُتل بأم
عيني ليس بشكل عام مثل ثلاثة
أشخاص رأيتهم يقتلون تمامًا
وكنا نصنع القبر لهم ، فأنت لا
تحفر نعم
في منطقتك  نعم
أخيرًا كان كل شيء كثيرًا في اليوم الأخير الذي
رأيت فيه والدي لأن والدتي كانت
محطمة عقليًا تمامًا ، أعني أنه كان مثل
اكتئاب كامل كان جالسًا في
القبو وحتى
هي لم تغادر السيلا  منذ
بداية الحرب بقيت في الداخل
لسوء الحظ
وفي اليوم الأخير رأيت والدي
وتوسل إلي مثل رجاء يا رفاق يغادرون إلى
مكان ما لا أعرف من أين أهرب فقط من
هذا وكان يبكي
ديميتري وزوجته وابنته  تكدسوا
في سيارة مع الأصدقاء وأمضوا 15
ساعة في القيادة عبر الخطوط الأمامية الروسية
هربًا من حصار ماريوبول
ورفض والديهم المغادرة لا
أعرف ما إذا كنت سأقابل والدي أو
أستمع لوالدي مرة أخرى لا أعرف  لا توجد
فكرة
أن الأمر يشبه العيش من يوم لآخر اليوم ،
فنحن على قيد الحياة غدًا ، ربما لا نعيش في
الأمان النسبي لهذه الممرات المصممة
للترفيه عن الأطفال ، حيث يرحب الأطفال
بالهروب من الصراع ،
وأريد حقًا أن أقول مرحباً للأطفال الآخرين ،
تانيا البالغة من العمر سبع سنوات
تقول الابنة فلادا وأريد أن تنتهي الحرب
بسرعة ،
يبدو أن والديها
مسكونان بصدمة واضحة تتلقى تانيا مكالمة من والدتها في
ماريوبو تبكي وتقول وداعًا
لأنها تخشى ألا تنجو
من الليل